since we have a whole company
and i was thinking like
he could maybe
train me like you know to take over the
company to keep the family name burned
did he really just ask to take over that
man's business
that's not gonna happen
it's it's just like he
he's out of his mind emily's dad reacts
after kobe says he wants to take over
his architecture company
but he has no real experience
this gave me flashbacks to andre wanting
free handouts from chuck are you gonna
give me the money or not that's what
thing is but at least kobe respects
emily's dad
hamlet's dad is a big guy and he's a
little intimidating i'm a little nervous
it was an awkward conversation to say
the least let's talk about it
hey 90 day fans fam it's melicia
nothing major went down this week but
there are some key moments i want to
show you to keep you in the loop and
keep our conversation going before we
get into kobe and emily shaida asked
below's 16 year old daughter zaina for
the second time how she feels about
calling her umi
which means mom
in my culture
whether we are connected or not
connected with an adult we refer to them
as umi
and as you can see zaina who is so cute
and confident by the way isn't feeling
it
me and my brother we call like
her and my stepdad by their first names
because that's like normal for us
i don't want to move too fast with the
names still getting used to her still
getting to know her she's my stepmom and
all that
but
i'm not ready to call her that yet also
i get that it's a cultural thing for
chida
but what's more important right now her
calling you umi or building a genuine
relationship because look this is a
teenager we are talking about here okay
they are quick to get turned off i hate
when you do that it's like you always
want to like you always do that and oh
yeah shadow below got in an argument
this episode wow what a surprise that's
crazy
she told him that he always feels like
he has to win conversations with her
basically he's so attached to being
right that he doesn't listen when she
voices her concerns
every time i try to bring up a problem
when it comes to bilal he deflects and
he brings it back on me
i have never argued so much in my life
ever with anyone ever speaking of an
argument
jabri and his best friend slash bandmate
david made up
after they started physically fighting
in the studio on last week's episode
following david's comments about miona
and how she's distracting jabri from his
music career like i care about you i'm
not against y'all i'm for you i want
y'all to succeed
it doesn't feel like that i know it
doesn't cause honesty it's straight up
it's it's i'm just being truthful is
david really from serbia
the way he talks you would never know my
mistrust was there and i'm honest about
it and you should respect that
he's such a smooth guy anyway once they
make up
interestingly enough jabrie starts to
believe that miona
is distracting him
i'm feeling a lot of doubt about
marrying meona and next week it looks
like he's going to do something about it
i don't feel any support from your
parents right now they're saying they
don't even want to come to our wedding
well that's absolutely fine that's not
absolutely fine with me though
debris should grow up and
stop thinking what they're thinking you
should focus on us if you want this to
work do you want this to work if it's
gonna be like this no
hmm
miana's makeup looks so good
i know random but it does
also just a heads up i'm talking to eve
soon about her relationship with
muhammad and his efforts to convert her
to islam i just feel like your
religion is too confining for me i'm a
very free spirit if you have any
questions for her drop them below and
i'll pick a few
all right moving on to kobe and emily
stressing her parents out especially her
dad you can tell that this man wants to
go off but
he's trying his best to hold his
composure
quick refresh last week kobe told emily
to shut the [ __ ] up i don't even need
your help
your ring's so rude
i'm being rude
can you just shut the [ __ ] up
and all of this went down in front of
her mom
essentially kobe was upset that emily
kept telling him how to clean up the
horse
and he felt as if he knew how to do it
and she was just being bossy and
controlling
either we're gonna figure this out or
this is not gonna work
after the incident emily made it clear
that she will not tolerate the
disrespect but do they do that in
africa um i'm not sure how i feel about
that comment but kobe went on to
apologize
now this week they get to spend some
quality time together without the baby
and emily's parents around which they
need because you can tell they're
starting to forget what it is they like
about each other in the first place
look at emily on the way to their date
it's your hand
i never feel my baby don't touch me
okay
for the last
kobe found it funny
all right babe
are you getting nervous
once it's time to ride horses kobe is
hesitant at first
i've never touched a horse in my life
but whenever we have you know a little
opportunity to spend time together i'm
just happy to do it oh
but he hops on
and it turns out to be a cute romantic
situation
i'm a pro check you out honey
your first time
you're doing amazing you're doing
amazing sweetie
i do feel like a proud parent look at
you babe but one good thing with us is
that we don't let the fighting ruin
whatever moment we want to experience
together yeah you can tell that this day
it helped them respark the romance in
their relationship
they have good chemistry a lot to work
through
but you can see how they fell in love
all right they get back to emily's house
and emily sits down with her parents to
ask if they can help pay for the wedding
and i just want you to pay close
attention to her dad's reactions
throughout the conversation
yeah it's still like so crazy that
kobe's here
it is crazy
her dad is like don't remind me
yeah
i'm spending my money taking care of you
him and the baby
we were talking earlier about like
how we haven't started planning the
wedding
i think i'm just like worried about
money
so
would you guys help with that
mr david is over it
currently um you know lisa and i are
paying for just about everything for for
emily
so
it's not surprising that emily would ask
us to pay for the wedding
but right now we don't know him that
well so he's got to prove to me that he
can provide for his family because i
ain't doing it
excuse my grammar but he left that part
out
emily's mom goes on to bring up kobe
telling emily to shut the [ __ ] up
which is something her dad had no clue
about
got mad because i was telling him what
to do and so he told me to shut up
emily i am shocked and appalled that's
inappropriate that's total disrespect
i mean
oh man
people argue so i'm not really that
people argue but you don't you cannot
let him speak to you that way it was
handled it doesn't need to be brought up
again it's fine and it was handled
emily's parents tell her that despite
all of their concerns they will help pay
for the wedding
but she needs to grow up they didn't say
that but we all know it's implied
and for context emily is 29 and kobe is
34.
are you gonna keep coming back every
couple of months and asking for other
things i mean some sooner or later
you're going to have to just say
we're on our own
she talks the talk and she wants to move
out and she wants to do this but she
doesn't have a clue
as to how to get from point a to point b
or
she doesn't have a clue sure i can
figure it out like everything else so
yeah i just don't see any evidence of
that emily has been spoiled by her
parents and i have too
but there comes a point where it hurts
to see your loved ones sacrifice so much
for you
when they have a life of their own that
they deserve to fully live
emily it's time girl make a plan write
it down take the necessary steps so kobe
i mean
i'm supporting a lot of a lot of people
here
speaking of a plan at this point kobe
doesn't have one
emily's dad set him down to have an
honest conversation about how he's going
to provide for his family
and to be honest his answer had me
nervous
so i can only imagine how emily's dad
felt
as far as plans i couldn't tell you know
emily was like maybe you could go back
to modeling
in kansas
there's no place like home kobe then
says he's interested in architecture
which is what emily's dad does he
explains that he has experience in civil
engineering
and the moment i start to think wow okay
this can actually work
kobe says this
since we have a whole company
and i was thinking like
you could maybe
train me like you know to take over the
company
and i was thinking like
he could maybe
train me like you know to take over the
company to keep the family name burning
kobe
y'all don't even share the same last
name and he just met you
to make it a worse after he tells mr
david he would like to take over his
company
he shares that his experience in civil
engineering
is from high school
you mentioned civil engineering and i'm
not sure exactly in cameroon did you get
a license there
was it what did you get a degree um i
had like high school
okay but did you have any training after
that no i didn't have any
and you want to take over
i know kobe has good intentions
i do
but
that doesn't make any sense
well he's crazy if he thinks he's going
to come in and take over my business but
that's not going to happen
it's it's just like he
he he's out of his mind
if you want to become an architect
that's probably a four or five year
program
you're going to have to figure out a way
to
pay for that the conversation ends with
emily's dad telling kobe that he and
emily need to sit down and seriously
figure out what they want their future
to look like it's not party in the usa
it's work work work
and i hope you're ready for it
although it can easily seem like kobe is
trying to freeload off emily's dad when
i spoke to him in april he did express
how grateful he is to mr david for his
support first of all
him accepting me to live in his house
without even knowing me
it's a plus i'm just so grateful that
i come i came into this family
all right next week it's binyam's first
amateur mma fight and ari is extremely
nervous about him getting hurt what if i
tell you i have a bad feeling about this
okay ari all daughter
don't worry and what if i ask you not to
not to fight tonight
[Music]
i can't wait to see how bingham does
with all the sacrifices ari has been
making he better win
i'm just saying
alright 90 day fans fam make sure you
stick with et because we are covering it
all i will see you next time
[Music]